bonsoir Aujourd'hui 26 novembre nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction et au
cours de la prochaine demi-heure nous
verrons notamment que des entreprises en
bouche encore notamment dans le commerce
mais pas uniquement à la verrière un
forum du recrutement vient de se tenir
autour de l'économie sociale et
solidaire les enfants aussi ont droit à
la parole alors que vient de se dérouler
la journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant nous recevons ce soir maître
Josiane Oléo toget elle plaide pour eux
à Versailles nous parlerons de la
profession d'avocats d'enfants poète
écrivain du début du siècle précédent
Antonin Artaud a laissé une œuvre
marquée par son adhésion puis son rejet
du surréalisme son travail est revisité
actuellement à la Maison de la poésie à
Guyancourt par Charles Gonzalez auteur
et metteur en scène
le conflit qui oppose les agriculteurs à
l'état est loin d'être terminé en cause
la décision du gouvernement de créer un
Front national de solidarité alimentée
par les fonds de roulement des chambres
d'agriculture celles d'Île-de-France
perdrait alors 490 000 euros l'année
prochaine ce qui représente plus de 6%
de son budget les teint imposerait
également une réduction de la recette de
la Chambre d'Agriculture issue de la
taxe sur le foncier payé par les
exploitants en impôt qui avait été gelé
pendant 10 ans avec cette réforme une
dizaine de postes pourrait être en
danger sur les 62 collaborateurs que
compte la chambre de la région
aujourd'hui l'État au vu de ses finances
catastrophiques jouent le prédateur et
vient ni plus ni moins prendre cet
argent qui était pourtant de la taxe
affectée c'est-à-dire que c'était bien
un impôt qui était affecté aux champs de
l'agriculture pour le ramener dans le
budget de l'État donc c'est une
spoliation pure et dure d'une partie des
sommes ensuite que l'impôt
soit laissé à ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne demande pas une augmentation de
la peau au moins qu'on nous laisse au
montant où il est aujourd'hui on nous le
fait baisser ce qui représente vous
l'avez vu en termes de Somme et de
conséquences pour le contribuable c'est
zéro 50 centimes de l'hectare ça ne
représente absolument rien et de
manifestation des agriculteurs est
prévue demain matin 27 novembre à 10h
dans le Val d'Oise emploi alors que le
chômage progresse toujours à un secteur
semble porteur celui de l'économie
sociale et solidaire d'autres métiers
auxquels on pense pas toujours mais qui
permettent de faire carrière la ville de
La Verrière vient de proposer un forum
hier avec de l'information mais aussi et
c'est important peut-être le plus
important des offres d'embauche
nous c'est le secteur du service à la
personne donc ça est principalement
auxiliaire de vie diplômé ou qui ont au
moins une partie de modules véhiculée ce
serait ce serait le moins profil ensuite
des aides ménagères et dans de la garde
d'enfants donc là la garde d'enfants
aujourd'hui avec les lois on va être
plutôt sur des personnes diplômées par
contre automatiquement diplômés
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est un des
secteurs d'activité qui a des besoins en
recrutement sans cesse ça recrute mais
aussi il y a aussi certaines méfiance
vis-à-vis aussi des entreprises donc
c'est aussi pouvoir montrer aux
entreprises que avec le social et
l'insertion on peut aussi avancer
ensemble et faire de de belles choses
emploi toujours et Renault qui annonce
le retour des trois huit dans son usine
de Flins à l'issue d'un comité
d'entreprise extraordinaire hier la
direction a annoncé la création d'une
équipe de nuit pour 2015 pour répondre à
une hausse des commandes notamment en
provenance de l'Espagne et de l'Italie
450 intérimaires supplémentaires serait
ainsi embauché 490 Clio 4 et 750 Zoé
seront produites chaque jour entre la
mi-février et la fin avril sur ce site
les droits des enfants nous venons de
fêter le 25e anniversaire de la
Convention qui les régit voici quelques
jours et nous voulions ce soir apporter
un focus sur une activité méconnue celle
d'avocats d'enfants bonsoir maître
Josiane oléotoguet et bienvenue vous
exercez auprès du Barreau de Versailles
pionnier dans ce domaine c'est le
premier en France à avoir lancé ses
avocats d'enfants au début des années 90
un avocat d'enfant un avocat pour enfant
ça sert à quoi
et bien comme le nom l'indique ça sert
déjà aux enfants un avocat d'enfant est
avant tout un avocat il faut savoir
qu'on n'est pas on ne n'est pas avocat
d'enfants on a une formation pour ça
après sachant que effectivement l'avocat
d'enfants est un avocat j'allais dire
bénévole dans ce domaine on a une
formation auprès de professionnels de
praticiens pour savoir accueillir
l'enfant pratiquer en tout cas avec lui
et puis pour tout ce qui est judiciaire
et bien évidemment ça on est à même par
notre profession d'avocat initialement
de pouvoir leur expliquer les arcanes et
puis le déroulement d'une procédure dans
laquelle ils peuvent être impliqués en
tant que auteur victime ou tout
simplement en tant que
participant si vous voulez notamment en
matière civile dans le cadre par exemple
de séparation d'un couple enfin de ses
parents
les enfants mais ce sont les enfants
directement qui peuvent solliciter et
demander un avocat alors en matière
pénale cela peut arriver oui la plupart
du temps de toute façon de nous
intervenons nous sur designations du
bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats de
Versailles il faut savoir que nous
intervenons aussi bien en civils en
matière civile qu'en matière pénale
matière civile c'est-à-dire comme je
vous l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure devant
le juge aux affaires familiales ou
devant le juge des enfants au tribunal
pour enfants en matière d'assistance
éducative donc tout ce qui nécessite une
protection de l'enfant et également en
matière pénale alors que l'enfant soit
auteur ou victime et donc dans un cas
comme ça nous sommes dans un en matière
civile nous sommes désignés et au titre
par le bâtonnier pardon et indemniser au
titre de l'aide juridictionnelle ce qui
aujourd'hui pose un autre débat puisque
vous savez que le problème de l'aide
juridictionnelle est véritablement sur
les avocats absolument donc là aussi il
peut y avoir une incidence effectivement
sur la sur le métier enfin sur
l'orientation d'avocats d'enfants et
puis en matière pénale nous intervenons
sur commissions d'office mais de toute
façon toujours sur désignations du
bâtonnier ou alors le choix d'un des
parents ça peut arriver aussi et
évidemment
deux fois par l'enfant lui-même parce
que il y a eu des campagnes de
médiatisation qui font que les enfants
savent dans les collèges ou l'alcool que
c'est possible directement les
informations qui s'affichent à l'écran
si jamais pour pour le secteur de
Versailles pour le Barreau de Versailles
c'est jusqu'à 18 ans logiquement pour
les mineurs à partir de quel âge partir
de quel âge d'enfants qui capable de
discernement c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où un enfant peut émettre des
propos peut avoir lui-même une espèce de
j'allais dire de conscience de la
situation oui alors la notion
discernement c'est très c'est très flou
je dirais un enfant de 6 ans peut avoir
moins de discernement qu'un enfant de 4
ans il m'est déjà arrivé de recevoir un
fond de quatre ans extrêmement volubile
et puis mes volubile dans le concernant
le sujet si vous voulez donc là je
discernement c'est il n'y a pas d'âge en
fait c'est le discernement donc c'est à
nous aussi d'apprécier savoir si
l'enfant rapporte des propos qu'il
aurait entendu ou il a lui-même avec ses
mots formulés quelque chose qu'on est à
même de rapporter par la suite donc
c'est un travail particulier vous l'avez
dit une formation complémentaire
supplémentaire à celle d'avocat comment
se passe l'échange avec les enfants
justement il y a presque un travail de
psychologue il y a un lien particulier
oui alors le lien il se crée ça c'est
inévitable où il le sait jamais ça peut
c'est ou là où l'autre mais en principe
effectivement il y a d'abord une
relation de confiance
il faut d'abord se présenter c'est la
première des choses qu'on fait parce que
il arrive quelquefois que l'enfant a
déjà vu assistante sociale psychologue
etc un certain nombre d'intervenants
avant nous et quelquefois l'enfant vous
dit mettez qui toi alors on reprécise
qui nous sommes et puis effectivement il
y a une approche la mise en confiance
recueillir la parole d'un enfant c'est
pas toujours aisé il faut aussi savoir
lui parler d'autre chose que j'allais
dire complètement ciblée immédiatement
sur le sujet effectivement on arrive à
avoir des relations extrêmement riches
la plupart du temps il y a des enfants
qui sont qui restent multiples aussi on
a défini du mal à les avoir mais en
principe quand il demande à parler à un
avocat d'enfant et qu'ils savent qu'ils
vont venir avec un voir un avocat
d'enfant il y a déjà une espèce de
comment dire de confiance qui s'installe
ils savent que nous intervenons que pour
eux ils ni pour papa ni pour maman et ni
pour l'auteur etc et donc on est
véritablement leur conseil donc il y a
une vraie relation de confiance de
passer en plateau c'était qu'il faut les
fallait bien comprendre qu'on n'était
pas dans une logique de l'enfant roi non
plus
accepter tout assimilé tout ce que
l'enfant dit il faut aussi avoir un
minimum de recul et bien évidemment on
est là aussi pour essayer de voir ce que
je vous disais à l'instant savoir si
l'enfant rapporte des propos qu'il a
entendu par exemple lorsque le parent
papa ou maman l'amène à notre cabinet
pour pouvoir l'entendre préalablement
dans le cadre de la procédure et ça nous
y tenons beaucoup nous le groupe
d'avocats d'enfants en tout cas
Versailles c'est de pouvoir recevoir
l'enfant une fois accompagné par papa
une fois accompagné par maman et il nous
arrive très très fréquemment en tout cas
moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion à plusieurs
reprises de le constater que les propos
sont plus tout à fait les mêmes ou qu'il
y a une liberté ou une pression en
fonction de qui amène l'enfant à nos
cabinets on peut prendre un exemple
concret et forcément vous vous doutez
qu'on va aborder ce sujet là c'est la
question d'Outreau 2004 possède procès
d'Outreau une douzaine d'enfants qui
sont reconnus victimes par la justice de
viol d'agression sexuelle premier
décembre 2005 vers dicte d'aquittement
général pour l'ensemble des accusés
naufrage judiciaires c'est le terme qui
est employé après encore aujourd'hui la
parole des enfants a pourtant pesé très
lourd puisque ils se sont ensuite
rétractés sur leur propos ils ont dit
avoir menti pourquoi la justice n'a pas
réussi à saisir à ce moment-là qu'il y
avait mensonges et dans quelle limite on
peut accorder à la parole de l'enfant
alors ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que il y a effectivement
des méthodes qui sont aujourd'hui bien
mises en place aussi bien par les
intervenants en amont à l'avocat
d'enfant c'est-à-dire les services de
police de gendarmerie donc là il y a
normalement des formations qui sont
mises en place comment
construction elle-même du dossier a été
faite je crois qu'effectivement il faut
se rendre compte que la parole de
l'enfant c'est pas c'est ce que nous
disons nous aux enfants en disant c'est
pas toi qui va décider de la décision
c'est le juge qui avec ce que tu vas lui
dire va prendre une décision va prendre
dans un certain sens donc déjà
déculpabiliser l'enfant par rapport à la
décision qui va être prise à cet
extrêmement important là dans l'affaire
d'Outreau on a vu effectivement que
j'allais dire les choses ont beaucoup
basculé par l'engrenage judiciaire c'est
vrai que on a immédiatique bien
évidemment je pense effectivement les
médias ont focalisé sur le naufrage
judiciaire comme vous l'avez très
justement indiqué sur l'intervention
d'un juge d'instruction ou les pressions
qu'il a pu y avoir et malheureusement je
pense que dans cette affaire là on a un
peu oublié
les victimes parce qu'il y en a eu
malgré tout et bon je n'étais pas dans
le dossier donc j'ai un petit plus un
peu plus de mal mais je pense
qu'effectivement
ça a été je veux dire le le le
l'instruction au sens large du terme pas
au sens uniquement judiciaire du dossier
n'a peut-être pas été fait avec la
délicatesse qu'il aurait fallu en tout
cas pour les enfants aussi dans cette
affaire je pense qu'on a un peu oublié
les enfants oui dans cette affaire il y
a d'ailleurs aujourd'hui des films qui
est sorti avec plusieurs débats qui sont
sur la parole de l'enfant comment
j'étais moi-même en formation lundi à
l'hôpital Mignot avec une chercheuse
canadienne qui qui adapte des méthodes
extrêmement intéressantes d'ailleurs
d'approche de l'enfant pas seulement
d'ailleurs pour nous avocat qui
intervenons je vous dis en fin de ligne
pratiquement juste au moment où le
procès a lieu mais pour tous les
intervenants nous précédons vous avez
l'habitude de chaque jour vous revenez
sur l'actualité à travers notre question
du jour micro-trottoir aujourd'hui nous
sommes allés vous demander quel poids
accorder quelle valeur accordée à la
parole de l'enfant dans un cadre
judiciaire voici vos réponses
je pense qu'il faut donner beaucoup plus
la parole aux enfants surtout en cas de
divorce partir d'un certain âge je pense
que les enfants ont droit de parole
savoir s'ils veulent aller plus avec le
papa ou la maman la vie des enfants
n'est pas suffisamment pris en compte
par la justice on doute peut-être de
leur de leur propos qui peuvent changer
d'un moment à l'autre je crois que les
enfants faut faire attention quand même
à ce qu'ils disent quoi on a toujours en
tête l'affaire d'Outreau donc avec ça on
peut se dire que quand même les enfants
ne disent toujours pas la vérité lors
d'une situation de divorce où j'ai
trouvé que la parole des enfants n'était
pas suffisamment écoutés l'avocat les a
reçu cinq minutes n'a pas beaucoup plus
discuté avec eux le juge c'est pareil
donc je trouve que c'est pas forcément
toujours suffisamment pris en compte pas
toujours suffisamment pris en compte sur
cet exemple concret oui c'est vrai
évidemment il y a des magistrats comme
des avocats qui ont pas forcément
j'allais dire cette et puis il y a des
enfants qui ne parlent pas il faut le
savoir aussi et c'est leur droit le
droit des enfants c'est aussi de garder
silence de ne pas vouloir prendre ni
partie bien évidemment tout pour papa et
maman mais ne pas vouloir prendre la
parole tout simplement donc après sur
les méthodes de d'accueil dans nos
cabinets ou par les magistrats
aujourd'hui je dois avouer que à
Versailles on a quand même une véritable
écoute et il y a beaucoup de
concertation de concertation pardon
entre le groupe d'avocats d'enfants et
donc les avocats des violemment et les
magistrats spécialisés j'allais dire
dans les mineurs qu'il s'agisse des
affaires familiales ou au tribunal pour
enfants
1990 la création de ses avocats
d'enfants quel bilan peut en faire
justement depuis 1990 sur les résultats
obtenus et ce qui a eu des évolutions
dans les méthodes aussi oui bien sûr il
y a eu effectivement des méthodes très
importantes on a aujourd'hui élaboré une
convention donc des avocats d'enfants
comment et justement qui nous indiquent
comment pratiquer j'allais dire avec un
enfant donc c'est extrêmement important
parce que effectivement le Barreau de
Versailles comme vous l'avez indiqué et
pionnier c'est-à-dire que quand même que
la France
ne signe la Convention de New York qui
date comme vous l'aviez indiqué de
novembre du 20 novembre 1990 le
barraudersaï était créé à créer ce
groupe d'avocats d'enfants en début
d'année 90 et la France n'a simplement
j'allais dire admis ou reconnu la
convention quand janvier 1993 donc
effectivement pionnier et on progresse
puisque effectivement on a été aussi
porteur j'allais dire de cette parole
auprès d'autres barreaux en France et en
aux Antilles également puisque ce ne
sont pas que des grands barreaux puisque
les barreaux périphériques de Paris qui
peuvent être considérés comme des
grands-parents aussi non pas eu de
groupes d'avocats d'enfants aussi
rapidement que Versailles pour
information les Antilles on peut
considérer que c'est un petit peu plus
loin mais viennent de signer cette
convention et plus récemment le barreau
de tour les avocats d'enfants combien il
y en a-t-il à Versailles
petite cinquantaine entre
alors c'est du volontariat c'est pas
bénévolat c'est du volontariat c'est à
dire que c'est les avocats c'est pas
tout à fait du bénévolat puisque je vous
ai dit que le problème de l'aide
juridictionnelle se poser aussi donc ça
c'est du volontariat donc c'est l'avocat
qui sent un qui se sent un intérêt pour
les enfants particuliers une fibre
particulière j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas il faut pas oublier que les enfants
sont l'avenir du monde donc peut-être
faudrait-il peut-être accorder un peu
plus d'intérêt à nos enfants pour éviter
peut-être d'avoir d'autres problèmes à
gérer sécurité ce serait une belle
conclusion merci beaucoup je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat d'enfants auprès du
Barreau de Versailles et les coordonnées
qui vont s'afficher peut-être une
dernière fois et si vous voulez prendre
des renseignements ou si vous êtes
enfant tout simplement saisir un avocat
vous en avez le droit merci encore on
reste dans le monde de l'enfant avec les
élèves de l'atelier et cinéma du collège
Sainte-Thérèse à Rambouillet ils sont en
plein tournage il réalise un
court-métrage qui sera diffusé dès
l'année prochaine au cinéma et dans
différents établissements scolaires les
bénéfices seront reversés au profit de
l'association Les Toiles Enchantées
Yolaine Torres et William elle
O
projecteur caméra et comédien le cinéma
a investi les couloirs du collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet un
court-métrage comique d'une quinzaine de
minutes est actuellement en tournage
deux élèves se retrouvent dans leur
établissement vide aucun professeur ils
vont mener l'enquête
une soixantaine de collégiens de
l'atelier cinéma sont mobilisés pour ce
projet ce sont eux qui ont écrit la
majeure partie du scénario ce qui me
plaît c'est qu'on manie donc les
instruments la perche le script le
clapet la caméra
des choses que tu découvres et
j'aimerais en faire mon métier et j'ai
appris que c'était aussi pour des
associations différentes et donc ça m'a
aussi poussé à le faire le film se
rapprocher dans plusieurs salles de la
région tous les bénéfices des ventes
seront reversés au profit de
l'association l'étoile enchantées c'est
une association qui se déplace dans les
hôpitaux et les IME pour projeter des
films récents aux enfants malades ou
handicapés donc nous on a voulu faire un
court-métrage comique pour qu'il soit
ensuite projeté en première partie des
films qui sont projetés dans les IME et
dans les hôpitaux un projet généreux qui
séduit aussi les professionnels du monde
du cinéma comme Alexandre gilet comédien
très actif dans le doublage connu
notamment pour être la voix de Frodon
dans le Seigneur des Anneaux il est l'un
des acteurs principaux de secours
métrage je trouve que c'est intéressant
de soutenir ce genre de projet
parce que bon on est quand même pas
amené à le faire systématiquement et là
de prendre un peu de son temps pour la
bonne cause c'est toujours bon à prendre
je trouve pour les pour tout le monde le
tournage est presque terminé il sera
diffusé dans les salles et au sein de
l'établissement dès l'année prochaine
on parle de culture dans ce journal
n'oubliez pas juste après le magazine
kiosque comme chaque mercredi pour un
point complet sur l'actualité dans ce
domaine sur les Yvelines direction pour
l'instant la Maison de la poésie à
Guyancourt qui accueille l'artiste
émetteur en scène Charles Gonzalez pour
un travail autour d'Antonin Artaud 15
personnes participent en ce moment à des
ateliers autour des textes de ce poète
du surréalisme
messieurs
les lois
la coutume
vous concède le droit de mesurer
l'esprit
15 personnes ont intégré cet atelier qui
va donc durer pendant 11 séances à
raison de 4 heures par session ils ne
sont pas comédiens ni artiste juste
passionné de poésie
la poésie me plaît oui oui ça me parle
c'est la construction c'est ce sont les
lettres la construction des mots voilà
donc les Français la matière grise c'est
un moyen de s'exprimer qui a gardé cette
fraîcheur de liberté qui peut-être hélas
n'existe pas dans d'autres domaines
artistiques moi-même je suis maintenant
à la retraite artiste peintre j'ai une
association depuis 20 ans où j'enseigne
effectivement or je regarde un peu ce
qui se passe dans le marché de l'art et
le vocalier liberté est devenu très
relative donc la poésie pour moi c'est
le domaine de la liberté pour la
première question à qui cette resto à un
personnage mental
quels sont tes exigences d'actent
très bien les gens ne sont pas des
acteurs mais des actants c'est à dire
des gens venant de de lieux tout à fait
différents et c'est une approche naïve
donc ça risque d'avoir de vraiment de
très bonnes surprises la façon de dire
Artaud est surprenante par des gens qui
qui ne font pas l'acteur quoi je vous
assure vous allez voir ça ça donne des
choses surprenantes le résultat de ces
ateliers sera à découvrir le 11 avril
prochain à la Maison de la poésie
oui
calories
la crédulité des peuples
une exposition un ophle-le-château qui
accueille jusqu'au qui accueille en ce
moment pardon le 9e Salon des
Photographes c'est jusqu'au 30 novembre
20 photographe convié et parmi eux de 5
continents que nous avons rencontrés
Jérôme Cherrier est un habitué du salon
cette année parmi ses photos des clichés
pris lors de son dernier voyage au Népal
un pays qui souligne le photographe
marque beaucoup un vrai dépaysement et
des émotions avant en fait je regarde
effectivement pas mal de livres photos
de ce qui peut se faire en photo
j'adapte aussi mon matériel je sais à
peu près ce que je vais prendre et puis
après c'est un petit peu d'improvisation
on se promène dans les rues on voit ce
qui se passe on essaie de faire des des
photos de rue des portraits c'est pas
mal d'improvisation tout en ayant un
petit fil rouge qui est pas mal d'humain
et le paysage et Jérôme Cherrier prépare
déjà sa prochaine expédition ce sera le
vietnamien Duhem lui aime l'univers
musical il capte les images de concert
un travail très technique il y a
toujours de l'inattendu dans les
concerts et c'est vrai qu'on est là pour
saisir des instances c'est pas des c'est
pas de la photo dirigée particulièrement
donc le l'objectif c'est de saisir un
petit peu des instants qui passent très
très vite
le père de lin a été photographe le père
de l'autre peintre autodidacte les deux
artistes ont baigné dans un univers
propice alors quand on leur demande de
décrire une bonne photo le premier mot
qui leur vient c'est émotion pour le
photographe le but c'est bien sûr de
générer des émotions aux gens qui la
regardent moi ce que j'aime c'est quand
les gens viennent et puis s'arrêtent
devant
Marcato en arrêt en fait c'est à dire
qu'il s'arrêtent pour la regarder et pas
juste passer à partir du moment où les
gens s'arrêtent et commencent à vous
parler de vos photos l'une de vos photos
c'est que pour moi je pense que le
contrat est réussi quoi quand on arrive
à capter la lumière de la bonne manière
à capter la bonne expression on peut on
peut être content de ces photos
l'exposition se termine le 30 novembre
20 photographes ils s'en conviés pas de
thématique commune la place est laissée
à l'éclectisme c'est d'ailleurs la
marque de fabrique du salut
le hip-hop a 50 ans en fait c'est 30 ans
avec l'anniversaire de la compagnie de
danse pionnière dans ce domaine black
blamber nous en avions déjà parlé dans
ce journal une édition spéciale est
d'ailleurs à revoir sur notre site
internet le week-end dernier en tout cas
de représentation organiser au prisme à
Élancourt deux représentation d'un
spectacle fil rouge de cette histoire de
Black blamber Mélanie poker est Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude pour les images
cette fois c'est une histoire de
génération à Black blamber c'est la
quatrième qui danse alors avec
travelling 22 danseurs anciens ou
nouveau se retrouvent ou se rencontrent
ça me fait tout drôle de danser parce
que bon il y a quatre générations là moi
je suis parti la première génération
donc ça me donne une force aussi de voir
comment ça a pris ça a pris vraiment
racine quoi c'est une famille pour moi
une famille donc même en étant avec
d'autres compagnies j'ai toujours un
oeil sur Black bombers parce que moi
c'est là où j'ai commencé déjà j'étais
même pas né alors que ça avait déjà
commencé
que je danse depuis pas longtemps et que
je puisse faire les 30 ans et
quelque chose quand même de gros c'est
une grosse expérience c'est un bon
moment c'est un gros moment même
j'espère que plus tard on pourra aussi
faire la même chose et faire peut-être
les 40 ans 50 ans peut-être plus mais
c'est 30 ans ce ne sont pas seulement
ceux de la compagnie
en spectateur leur inspiration 30 ans à
limite 28 ans 30 ans et demi dans le
fond peu importe ce qui est très
important c'est que ça nous permet de
saisir une occasion de rappeler
l'importance
de la participation des habitants à leur
propre récit au récit de leur ville à
l'histoire de leur ville nous nous
incarnons
un moment de cette histoire les
associations les habitants sont co
générateurs
qu'aux élaborateurs co-créateur de leurs
histoires leur petites histoires
histoire d'une petite bande pour un
carnaval c'est la grande histoire ça
n'est que des petites histoires bon et
bien tout ça ça construit un récit ça
fait une ville black blamber continue de
raconter ces histoires le 17 décembre
l'accompagnait B3 junior présentera à
Trappes la version intégrale de paradoxe
avec le regard tourné vers l'avenir
c'est la fin de cette édition du 26
novembre à revoir sur notre site
Internet ainsi que l'intégralité des
reportages excellents de soirée à jeudi
toujours 18h pour le direct et 19h pour
la première rediffusion